foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
set to join us the Minnesota Vikings
quarterback and star of the Netflix
series he joins us on the program what
did you think when Netflix came to you
and said hey we want to do this with you
Marcus Mariota and Patrick Mahomes
questions Dan uh the big the big one
that made me feel comfortable as they
said you'll have the ability on the back
end to approve the content and I said
okay because I've been burned a lot in
the past when you know people uh have
access and then you don't get to see
what they do with it and then they take
it a direction you didn't think was was
happening so the chance to see the
content approve it was a big deal and
then the fact that NFL films was the was
the you know the middleman if you will
filming it and editing it I just felt
there was a lot of trust there knowing
that they would know how to handle it
how to do it and then a big one was just
their ability to to it in a way that was
non-intrusive so that people in our
organization didn't feel like it was
obnoxious or in their way or affecting
our our team as we went through the
season so it was done in a great way
couldn't have been done better and
obviously when you have a positive
season when the division have a lot of
close wins it made for a great story so
um you know at first I was ill like I
said I had a lot of questions but a lot
of those questions got answered quickly
and I thought what the heck let's do it
what's the reaction been from the family
it's funny because we talk about how
fans have been able to see a little bit
more behind the scenes but it doesn't
stop there it's really family too uh I
tell them a lot you know they're around
a lot but there's still so much that
they don't see don't know aren't a part
of and I think even they watching it you
know my brother my parents a sister they
all say boy we didn't realize it was
like that or like this so it's been a
real positive thing got a lot of good
feedback and um you know it was a
privilege to be a part of it you know it
humanized you which is kind of strange
we don't we look at you as a quarterback
not a person and then this allows us to
see the person behind the quarterback
who who is the quarterback
yeah no doubt I think that was part of
the goal was to allow people to see all
that goes into it and um and the impact
it can have when you win the impact it
can have when you lose and how it
affects you and and you know fans get a
great look in for three hours on Sunday
but to give them a look in the rest of
the week I think is really cool and um
you know Netflix
had other sports shows that have done
well whether it was the Formula One the
tennis the golf and I think it was time
for you know the NFL and football to get
out there as well and so this was a
great way to be able to do it
Mahomes language though was a little
shaky if you got the kids around
watching this
well he's an awesome guy and uh really
enjoyed getting around him a couple of
times I've been around him especially at
the premiere that we had a few weeks ago
but as we left the theater uh he he put
his arm around me and kind of joked he
said yeah I got to clean up the language
I laughed I said you're good man you
know I'm in an NFL locker room just like
you are and honestly it you know it may
not be the best thing but it probably is
a more accurate reflection of what it's
like in the NFL than uh than if it was
all PG so uh
um you know he was the first to say it
and uh I'll probably wait a couple years
to show it to my boys because of that
but you better believe they'll be seeing
it have you ever said you know watch the
language during a game if if somebody's
using any kind of language
what a great question I've never been
asked that uh no I've never told anybody
to mind their language
although it's not a bad idea Dan maybe
we could start doing that I could be you
know people tell me I dress like a dad I
act like Dad I could just carry that
over to just you know telling everybody
their potty mouth but uh no you know and
even it I'll slip out of me too you know
and when uh you get frustrated you
better believe that there's some words
that come out that I regret so it's a
part of uh you know part of the grind of
football and uh you know certainly you
try not to make it a habit what did you
think when Aaron Rodgers left the uh
division
oh the neighborhood changed a little bit
you know I remember when I first signed
in the NFC North in uh 2018 and and you
know that you know there's a guy named
Aaron Rodgers you know one stayed over
who's who's pretty good and uh you know
I thought he was always a great
challenge to go against in a way it was
really fun you know going against one of
the best to ever do it twice a year
um you know I thought that was a real
privilege and then now that he's moved
on I think you're always interested to
see okay you know what's next and it's
not just it's not just Green Bay with
Jordan love but I think even Chicago
with Justin skills you know you see the
talent the ability and and then what
Detroit is doing and this you're the
Jared Goff and their offense had last
year you know you realize there's a lot
of up and coming players and I've been
around this league long enough to see
how you know the next stars are coming
the minute uh Rivers retires there's a
Justin Herbert on the way so
um you know you know that could be true
too in your own division you're talking
to Kirk Cousins Vikings quarterback we
and Steve Young on a couple of days ago
and he said the days of Peyton Manning
and Dan Marino that kind of quarterback
those are long gone that we won't have
the pure pocket passing quarterback what
do you think
so I've asked that same question many
people because I happen to be a pocket
passing Court yes so I'd like to know if
I I'd like to know if my job's gonna be
extinct so uh so so uh Matt Kavanaugh
who played 14 years I think he might
have played with Steve Young or coach
with Steve Young
um you know he was my quarterback coach
in Washington so I asked Kev I said you
know you think the days of like being a
pocket Pastor over and this was years
ago and he said Kurt you know certainly
being able to move around as an asset
but he said if you can't from the pocket
go through a progression see cover see
the field recognize protections and
blitzes and throw with accuracy it
doesn't matter what else you can do and
if you can do those other things that's
a big if then absolutely to have that
other ability as an added bonus but he
said you better be able to throw with
accuracy and do all the things that
pocket pastors who are Elite can do and
I think that was a great point that the
foundation of it all is you got to be a
pocket passer and if you can do that
then add that trait and I think that's a
huge bonus and I even asked that
question of uh of a retired quarterback
this offseason that I met with I said
you know do I need to become more of a
of a runner and and uh an off-scheduled
player so that's an area my game I'm
always trying to improve and he said
well he said I knew when I hurt my knee
I could still go out and troll for 300
yards and four touchdowns but if I was a
running quarterback and I hurt my knee I
really wouldn't be able to be the guy
that you know I was being paid to be and
so he said really from the salary cap
perspective from a strategic perspective
quarterbacks can still be a great pocket
passer even when they're beat up but
it's hard to be that Elite off schedule
Runner and playmaker if you're beat up
and so he said I always felt like it was
better for my team if I knew I could
throw from the pocket because of what I
could do even if I was beat up help me
understand the context of this Justin
Jefferson was asked about the top five
quarterbacks or didn't include you in
the top five quarterbacks and then your
reaction to that was hey he's got his
opinion do I have that right
yeah I didn't even see the context
either I didn't see how he was asked it
or what his response was I'm sure he's
just shooting from the hip and uh I know
that I'd love to I have a year together
with him where next year when he lists
off the top five you know my name comes
to the top of his mind right away but do
you think you're a top five quarterback
uh I think it's a good question I think
it's a little bit where and this this is
uh something I even say would be
debatable I I look at it and I go
there's a little bit of like Mahomes at
the top and then there's like a lot of
other guys down to like much deeper than
five if you will and then there's kind
of another there's another uh you know
deal where you got guys who are
developing and working their way through
it I think we all have great games we
all have the clunker games and
um you know I think that uh
quarterbacking is so much about winning
and you got to win football games to
kind of get put into that upper tier of
being a top five guy and you know we we
were in the playoffs last year we lost
our first playoff game and so it's hard
to be put in that category if you're not
playing in Conference Championship games
and playing in Super Bowls and winning
Super Bowls and so that's really where
you know for me it's all about winning
and team and I think I think you're
stalling you're stalling on giving me an
answer there
you know Dan I don't
know it's very uh helpful for me in any
way to give you a direct answer there
you're welcome to ask the question but
I've been around the block okay all
right it doesn't help me but veteran
maneuver if Netflix asks you are you
gonna answer their question
well Dan I have a right to edit all the
time that's true
uh well uh always great to talk to you
hope family is good and thanks for
joining us
absolutely thanks guys Kirk D cousins
joining us I was wondering if he would
say yeah I'm a top five quarterback
we're trying to make some headlines here